dans les moments clés dans les dents
libres dans les meilleurs moments vous
par exemple isabelle morini-bosc c'est
quoi votre meilleur moment dans tpm p
moi mon meilleur moment qu'elle n'était
pas mauvais à un meilleur moment à vivre
quand ça s'est passé à mai 2008
c'était quand on est allé à las vegas
tous ensemble et que à cause de ce
bâtard de matthieu delormeau
alors ça c'était magique avec camille
combal également cani alors qu'amy qui
nous avait laissé une petite vidéo qu'on
verra demain parce que vous allez voir
demain on va faire un gars qui on verra
demain c'est ce que je pense qu'on va
continuer l'anniversaire de main on a
tellement pas fait plein de trucs
puisqu'on v doit gagner on va faire il
veut gagner des milliers etc
voilà on ne me reste qu'à me regarder
c'était à las vegas avec camille pour
mon mariage avec lui c'était un aux
meilleurs souvenirs ça aussi et vous
aussi regarder et n'importe quoi
derrière comment ça fait garder ce qu'on
fait on s'arrête camille bien aidé par
cyril faut l'avouer à une super idée la
meilleure idée de ces quinze dernières
années
ipic les clés de la voiture de mathieu
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il s'est fait voler réglé plus tard ce
pays sans hausser qu'on attend va je
reviens du stic du reste là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un mois
oui
[Rires]
d'un coup
[Musique]
oui
m
[Musique]
c'était un grand grand grand moment un
an marque abbey bien sûr nord-ouest où
se crée avec nous et voilà ça c'est le
meilleur souvenir d'isabelle morini-bosc
un ca bernard montiel
quant à quand on t'a dit si on voulait
que tu fasse partie des missions tata
tout de suite dit oui tu as tout de
suite qui fait l'idée ou pas ouais ouais
bien sûr d'abord d'abord je connais
c'est l'émission parce que je la regarde
et je la trouvais tellement rappaz est
tellement délirante
tu veux que j'avais eu vraiment envie
d'y participer comme moi c'est toujours
difficile c'est de trouver sa place
effectivement parce que chacun sait à
trouver et n'a défini et puis voilà j'ai
essayé de m'adapter
je me suis baladé et je serai toujours
plaisir et battait un amour alors
mathieu c'est quoi ton plus grand
souvenir toi mon cher un coup de jeune
et plein plein plein et renner choisir
qu'un don il faut dire qu'un moyen que
j'ai vraiment rigolé parce que je me
suis fait prendre au piège et que
c'était perdu parce je suis tombé dans
le piège comme les téléspectateurs
c'était la folie un acteur très connu un
acteur anglais qui s'appelle sasha
barrese marathon oil arabe aura
exactement gaga énorme carton états unis
et quitter a mis des menottes et comme
ça a duré une heure quarante je pense
tout à fait vraiment vraiment je suis
vraiment rentré dans le jeu à mort et
comme tout le monde on a fait un quart
mais je vous dirais je vais vous
raconter l'histoire cette séquence après
et regardez c'est le moment préféré de
mathieu ne sont pas très bien
[Rires]
c'est parti
mua
[Applaudissements]
et même si j'allais quand je suis arrivé
ça sert cette connerie on pouvait
trouver cela je commence à être pas bien
j'en sais pas bien ce que ma mère j'aime
pas me sentir la non j'aime bien qu'avec
toi toi et je crois que toi je te kiffe
est ce que tu crois qu'il a vraiment
perdu la trace il a un trou dans sa
poche le gard on sait pas au moins à
claymont frère le gall la compil au
téléphone mon frère au direct moi je
fais des bisous csna bat tous les jours
contre la concurrence avait levé
m'attraper en fait comme si j'étais pas
là
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
cette attention la rue jean amila la
mare où les gars c'est risqué mais il
est trop vous êtes allez les gars allez
merci tu verras
[Applaudissements]
on suivre et clark royer comment on
valorise et ça non
sa main est là non ça marche pas quelle
connerie pas celle de la toison loi a
tancé ne dis pas que c'est la clé soirée
merci c'est la clé non si c'est là que
les civils
virez les tous a fait devenu pour rien
enfin non je suis pas venu pour rien hu
[Applaudissements]
voilà alors il y avait déjà mal de
boulot mon frère on sait que tu es un
bouquet ce jour là et je vous le dis
franchement moi j'avais j'ai été pris
dans le jeu il ya plein de gens qui
pensaient que j'étais vraiment aux nerfs
mais on avait prévu le truc après c'est
vrai que tous tout ce qui était le
serrurier tout ça tout ça c'était
improvisé
il m'avait juste te dire on va te mettre
les menottes et après on s'est dit tiens
on va faire tenir le truc pendant une
heure et demie mais le serrurier et le
truc l'accueil qu'on trouve pas tout ça
voilà jamel debbouze qui était pas au
courant et c'est tout ça c'était c'était
de l'intro jeu